le tout nouveau champion de france de
boxe professionnelle la catégorie 50 kg
arbore fièrement son titre à la salle de
boxe les plus jeunes sont admiratifs
un titre qui récompense des années de
travail tous les boxeurs de sable on
n'est jamais au poids donc faut toujours
faire des régimes un peu draconien pour
perdre entre 3 et voire plus
des stylos toujours toujours en trop il
faut être toujours au top aussi donc
toujours à découvrir toujours ne pas
faire beaucoup
extra est toujours sérieuse
anthony chapados 22 ans a commencé en
boxe éducative il ya dix ans la boxe
professionnelle
il ya rarement ils vont défendre son
tout nouveau titre ici à montargis une
belle promotion pour un club déjà
victime de son succès actuellement on a
150 licenciés
et donc c'est vrai on a refusé du monde
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de l'espace
pour pouvoir accueillir tout le monde
l'autre pur produit du club c'est
christian m billy il y a quelques mois
le boxeur amateur s'est hissée jusqu'en
quarts de finale aux jo de rio pour son
entraîneur c'est une fierté de former
des champions
je suis pas du sel entraîné plusieurs
entraîneurs au niveau de la salle ça
leur permet d'apprendre plusieurs styles
de boxe et c'est peut-être pour ça aussi
que ça l'est mènent plus vite au niveau
à 21 ans christian m billy est en passe
de devenir professionnel six ans après
ses débuts au club de montargis
aujourd'hui je niveau de vie
de mon sport aujourd'hui je pense que
j'ai suffisamment de demandes pour en
vivre et un mois maintenant de de faire
le bon choix avec son agent il étudie
des offres de promoteurs français et
étrangers il annoncera sa décision à la
fin du mois